en este cambio de gabinete finalmente el
presidente alberto fernández y la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández de
kirchner los dos algo pudieron conseguir
pero se puede decir que ella le torció
el brazo él ella fue la que venía
pidiendo que hubiera un cambio de
gabinete y se relanzará el gobierno tras
la derrota del domingo pasado en las
primarias legislativas y eso ocurrió
siete puestos se modificaron el
presidente logró conservar a santiago
cafiero que deja de ser jefe de gabinete
y pasa al ministerio de relaciones
exteriores ahora la jefatura de
gabinetes de juan manzur gobernador de
la provincia de tucumán y un hombre que
había sido muy crítico de cristina
fernández de kirchner y ahora fue ella
misma quien lo propuso para conformar
parte de este nuevo gabinete o
parcialmente renovado porque la realidad
es que todos aquellos funcionarios
cercanos a cristina kirchner que habían
presentado la renuncia públicamente
ninguno dejó el gobierno con la
excepción de roberto álvarez a ministro
de ciencia y técnica pero cuado de pedro
eduardo depedro el ministro del interior
hombre clave y muy cercano a cristina
fernández el primero que presentó la
renuncia no se fue tampoco se fue el
ministro de economía martín guzmán
hombre clave de alberto fernández ni
matías kulfas otro alfil de economía en
el ministerio de producción un área que
fue especialmente criticada por cristina
fernández se sostendrá esta tregua
aguantar a este cambio ministerial es
algo que todavía resta verse